there's really no excuse because we know
what is at stake here we've been hearing
it all week we heard it from the the
president of palau sir angel whips
who told me he spent five days traveling
seven and a half thousand miles across
nine time zone time zones uh to make
sure that the voice of his his people
was heard
and the least we can do is
pay attention
when he says that if the big economies
don't do more we and i quote might as
well bomb his islands we heard it from
simon coffey from the government of
tuvalu who spoke to us not from a podium
in a cozy conference room but knee deep
in a steadily rising pacific ocean and
we heard it from the prime minister mia
motley of barbados who so moved us on
the opening ceremony when she warned
that we are digging our own graves and
asked when are the leaders finally going
to lead and so i say to my
my fellow leaders
if you stood and applauded her then
you cannot now sit on your hands
as the world asks you
to act because the world knows what a
mess our planet is in
the world has heard leaders from every
country continent stand here and
acknowledge the need for action and
the world will find it absolutely
incomprehensible if we fail to deliver
that and the backlash
from people will be immense and it will
be long lasting and frankly we will
deserve
their criticism and their opprobrium
because we know what needs to be done
and we all agree
what needs to be done we just need the
courage actually to get on and do it
so now is the time for everyone to come
together and show the determination
needed to power on through the blockages
to look at the science with
dispassionate eyes and think about how
we can compromise how we can be flexible
to meet the needs of the planet and for
world leaders who are now back in their
capitals
to pick up the phone
to their teams here
and give them the negotiating margin
give them the space they need in which
to maneuver and get this done
here
in glasgow
the world is closer than it has ever
been
to signaling the beginning of the end of
anthropogenic climate change and it's
the greatest gift we can possibly bestow
on our children and our grandchildren
and generations unborn and it's now
within reach
at cop 26 in these final days we just
need to reach out together
and grasp it and so my
question
to my fellow world leaders this
afternoon as we enter the last hours of
cop is will you help us
do that will you help us
grasp that opportunity or will you stand
in the way